ja in der heutigen Sitzung geht es um
ein weiteres spannendes Thema im Kontext
der Philosophie der Aufklärung nämlich
um die Enzyklopädie die Enzyklopädie von
dünne diedero und Salon Bär hier sind
die beiden
Enzyklopädisten abgebildet die
Enzyklopädie die hatte zahlreiche Bände
und entstand im Rahmen von vielen
Jahrzehnten insgesamt mehr als 70.000
Artikel umfasste diese
Enzyklopädie es waren über 100 Autoren
dran beteiligt einige anonymen viele
auch mit Namen
da kann man sich natürlich dann auch
fragen wie hängt diese Enzyklopädie mit
der heutigen Enzyklopädie des Internets
mit Wikipedia zusammen da machen wir
noch eine eigene Sitzung dazu
ich möchte mich heute einführen weil es
zwei Sitzungen zu diesem Thema der
Enzyklopädie als Phänomen der Aufklärung
der öffentlichen Vernunft dem
öffentlichen Gebrauch der Vernunft mit
kann zu sprechen geben wird nur mit
einem Artikel befassen ich verrate
gleich mit welchem es gibt eine sehr
schöne deutsche Auswahl eine Übersetzung
auf dieses Bild im Hintergrund werde ich
noch genauer zu sprechen kommen der
heutigen Sitzung und hier gibt es mal so
eine Auswahl an Artikeln in Deutsch
Übersetzung ich hatte ja gesagt 70.000
das ist nur eine Handvoll das ist gerade
zu verschwinden gering viele Artikel
aber man kann hier schon mal so ein
bisschen was sehen es gibt interessante
Artikel Freiheit ist natürlich immer
interessanter Artikel denkfreiheit hängt
auch mit aufklären zusammen natürliche
Freiheit aber natürlich auch
andere Begriffe
wie etwa den Fanatismus oder auch den
Aberglaube das sind natürlich auch
Begriffe die problematisch sind wir
werden uns heute aber nur mit einem
Begriff befassen nämlich mit dem Begriff
der
Enzyklopädie also die Enzyklopädie
enthält selbst ein Artikel zu Ihrem
Thema das ist ganz interessant und was
ist jetzt eine Enzyklopädie eine
Enzyklopädie soll laut dieser
Enzyklopädie
die auf der Erdoberfläche verstreuten
Kenntnisse sammeln das allgemeine System
diese Erkenntnisse die Menschen darlegen
mit denen wir zusammenleben und es den
nach uns kommenden Menschen überliefern
damit die Arbeit der vergangenen
Jahrhunderte nicht nutzlos für die
kommenden Jahrhunderte gewesen ist als
eine Enzyklopädie hat eine Zeit
Vollstreckung hat ein Ziel was über ihre
Herkunft ihre Entstehung hinausweist es
geht um das Bewahren und das Ordnen des
Sammeln von Wissen und das soll dazu
führen dass
die Menschen nicht nur gebildeter
sondern auch tugendhafter werden da
verweise ich auf froh so zurück oben
rechts der gerade gesagt hatte durch die
Aufklärung werden wir nicht tugendhafter
sondern
unmoralischer ja also dass darum geht es
es geht um ein Sammeln ein
systematisches sammeltes der verstreuten
Wissensbestände es geht um die
Organisation des Wissens das auf der
Welt verstreut zu finden ist deswegen
hat die Aussage die auch nicht nur
wissenschaftlich Artikel sondern auch
wissenschaftliche sondern auch Artikel
über Künste und Berufe
also ganz praktische Themen versammelt
hier geht es jetzt so um dass die
Enzyklopädie sich nicht als eine
wissenschaftliche Abhandlung versteht
sondern
um eine
also meine Form geht eine hier steht
Koordination des Artikels
die darin besteht dass die Artikel auf
andere Artikel verweisen und das gibt es
eben in dem wissenschaftlichen
Abhandlungen der Regel nicht weil die
einfach zu wenig Umfang haben die sind
zu wenig vernetzt mit innerlichen
Strukturen und eine Enzyklopädie die
70.000 Artikel hat können wir als ein
kleines verweisungsnetz als ein kleines
Internet verstehen alles geht um die
Verweise mit heutigen Worten um die
Hyperlinks und die Links die
hypertextuellen Verknüpfungen haben das
ist der wichtigste Teil der
enzyklopädischen Ordnung natürlich kann
man hier nicht nur einmal draufklicken
sondern muss eben immer wieder dann
einen anderen Band nehmen ich habe ja
viele Bände an der richtigen Seite
aufschlagen das heißt es hat schon Mühe
gemacht diese Verweise herzustellen oder
den Verweisen nachzugehen und jetzt wird
hier zwischen zwei Arten von Verweisen
unterschieden die von den Dingen und die
von anderen Wörtern es geht natürlich
interessanterweise in der Philosophie
nicht um Wörter sondern um Dinge oder
auch ein Begriffe aber deswegen befassen
wir uns jetzt nur mit den Verweisen von
Dingen
also hier
werden entfernte Verbindungen
hergestellt so dass begriffliche Inhalte
nicht isoliert stehen es wird also immer
ein Kontext hergestellt aber vielleicht
auch Gegensätze
sichtbar gemacht und die verstärken die
Folgerungen also wir können dadurch zu
Schlüssen gelangen auch zu
eigenständigen Schlüssen über die
Wissensbestände wir erhalten einen
Überblick eine Organisation dieser
Wissensbestände die nicht nur Additiv
alphabetisch angehäuft werden sondern
eben organisiert werden durch Verweisung
Systeme das heißt wir haben verschiedene
Ordnungssysteme in der Enzyklopädie eine
alphabetische wortordnung und eine
systematische
verweisungsordnung die natürlich viel
wichtiger ist ja und diese Folgerung
verknüpfen den Zweig mit dem Stamm und
verleihen dem Ganzen jene Einheit welche
der Durchsetzung der Wahrheit und der
Überzeugung so förderlich ist also
Wahrheit gibt es nur im System im
genauer gesagt im
verweisungssystem und hier gibt es jetzt
noch einen wichtigen Punkt dass auch
Begriffe in Opposition geraten können
durch Verweisungen
so dass man sich seine eigene Meinung
bilden muss wenn man dieses
Enzyklopädie liest man liest sie nicht
von A bis Z sondern verließt sie
gewissermaßen springend und hüpfend und
verknüpfend
und das ist also ganz ganz zentral jetzt
wird hier auf die Metapher des Stammes
gebracht als ein Wissensstand
CO2 gehabt ich darf noch mal an das
Titelbild dieser deutschen Ausgabe
erinnern und da gibt es ein Zoom hinein
man sieht hier alle das ist der Stamm
und hier sind die Zweige der Stamm ist
die Vernunft Französisch la memoir das
Gedächtnis die Erinnerung und
limagination also die
Einbildungskraft die verschiedene Zweige
darstellen hier sieht man noch mal den
gesamten Wissensbaum
in Zeilen einzeln Feststellungen
darauf werden wir auch noch genauer
eingehen auf diese Wissensorganisation
ist ein Organismus
ein System das der Natur nachempfunden
ist die Natur Metapher spielte eine
wichtige Rolle Stamm und zwei Gewürze
ist natürlich auch eine wichtige
Metapher
jetzt ist es ganz interessante dass es
nicht nur darum geht dass die Artikel
miteinander vernetzt sind
es heißt die Enzyklopädie betrifft nicht
nur sich selbst sondern gewissermaßen
performativ auch die Menschen die
Personen die die entwickli benutzen ja
das heißt es soll damit die übliche die
allgemeinübliche Form des Denkens
verändert werden
durch die Form der Verweise das ist
natürlich ein performative Aspekt der
über die die bloße werkstruktur
hinausgeht und auf den Rezipienten die
rezipientin verweist und darin sieht man
natürlich auch ein ganz klar an
aufklärerischen gestos also eine innere
Kraft und ein geheimer nutzen diese
Enzyklopädie eine performative Kraft
das ist
die
aufklärerische Intention der
Enzyklopädie ja das war ein ganz kurzer
Einblick in den Artikel Enzyklopädie der
aussieht lobedie wir werden in der
nächsten Sitzung während von weiteren
Artikeln die Bedeutung die
aufklärerische Bedeutung dieses
wichtigen Werks des 18 Jahrhunderts
weiter diskutieren